lid we're back
everybody's always sunny in philadelphia
i guess it's just glenn and charlie
charlie how you doing bud i'm doing
pretty good glad i'm doing pretty good
we're not together in the studio and
unfortunately we can't be together in
the studio due to a major license
pinworm outbreak thanks to rob mcelhenny
uh he's at home he's getting cleaned up
and hosed down uh but we've got worms
coming out of every inside outside
there's worms everywhere
unfortunately we can't be around him um
but uh that's only the good news is that
it should be completely cleared out of
his system within a good eight to ten
weeks
so uh you know
you can only anticipate maybe 10 15 of
these zooms to be safe
and then hopefully uh
the worms have eaten the lice and then
we can attack the worms and uh and clear
it all up
we need we need like uh worms that kill
other worms you know what i mean like
you just send in like an army of worms
to take out the uh yeah the other worms
you know is that a thing they yeah they
got those camera head worms but what if
they turn into ghost worms and ghost
lice and then we get a deal yeah that's
a whole thing
oh my god think of all the
all the bugs that we've killed and all
the ghosts of bugs that are out there
you know if and if you were the type of
person who could see
you know that type of thing like the
like what is it like not a paranormal
but like a psychic i guess
boy
i thought about that the other day
because you know we we had the argument
about ghosts and why you don't see a
warm ghost of a worm and then you know
as my mind tends to do then later i have
a counter argument with myself um and uh
and started questioning well maybe
of worms see ghost worms
and uh you know and humans only see but
if you're a worm you might see the ghost
of a worm you know
so it could be you know you're tapped
into
you know whatever you're tapped because
the worm doesn't even see us do they i
don't know what a worm sees worms blind
i think
i think a worm is flying
anyways we're back on the sunny podcast
and talking about worms again
[Music]
okay uh mac is a serial killer um
i
loved this episode
i did too
i did too yeah i loved it i've always
loved it and i love it now
i want to say something on the record
like
i've enjoyed all these episodes i know
sometimes maybe the fans hear us being
analytical and they're
they might mistake that for a dislike of
the episode i think that's us just
trying to understand where we were how
we got to where we got to
and um you know where we are today so we
can make the episodes
as best as we can but um
the more as they go along i like the
more and more
the character dynamics i mean we really
and we're building out the world in this
one in a great way with the with the
moms and uh and mac's dad
and cricket
this is the first time we did the lawyer
gag i think it's so great and it's very
funny
it's great
yeah no it's it's terrific and i and i
also love how you you kind of slip into
the uh you kind of slip into the whole
shelly the machine levine uh thing again
whenever you put on the short sleeve
button-down shirt
and the and the tie
you be you sort of become jack lemon and
glengarry glenn ross yeah he likes to
play adult uh
right right
um
i mean i what i love that just the
interview of mac's mom like
interrogating her
oh man that's so good yeah no i i
absolutely love this episode i thought
it was great i love the lawyer stuff is
so funny to me um
just you thinking
that you've watched enough episodes of
law and order
that you think you understand you like
you know the sort of the key phrases and
terms and you feel like you could get in
there
and actually defend someone and you know
with that knowledge and uh
it's um
yeah i don't i don't know it's just it's
so stupid but it's it's it's so funny
it's a it's like a shtick but it's a fun
shtick
uh my favorite is the scene where you're
talking to mac and you're like i gotta
get in there and dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun you just start doing it yeah start
singing the law and order theme song
it's so funny
it's kind of funny trying on
did you ever wear
dracar noir was that do you have any
good cologne from your youth that you
used oh well
oh yeah absolutely i had it i had um
i really liked that uh calvin klein
obsession
sure um
yeah yeah that was that was my first
cologne
no i think i smelled like right guard
or something yeah yeah secret okay
just just the jacquard warren reference
is just so funny to me because it was
it's like a it's a very specific thing
right it's it's
to like the average person it it's like
it feels like a very expensive very
fancy cologne and yet you know it's like
in every department store and it was
like one of the most you know ubiquitous
colognes out there but uh
but to characters like our characters
we're like whoa
like
that's just kids do that like
catch on and become sort of just funny
like like body acts or whatever like
things that are like
targeted for men and taken very
seriously that seem very not serious and
are fun to make fun of glenn you as um
the uh to catch a predator guy oh so
funny yeah chris that's so young and
attractive is she mac
are you here to see a young attractive
woman or sandy a young attractive blonde
and then d comes out with a camera
you must be very disappointed
i loved it especially you had so many
good um runs at dee's expense this
episode the whole thing about like he'd
spend all day cutting you up he'd never
get the job done he'd get the job done
is this the episode that we came up with
calling dear bird
well because okay sir larry bird
we've talked about this a little bit um
we did call her big bird in season two
uh when she's when she when she had on
the basketball suit yeah when she had
the basketball suit on where were we
yeah the pantsuit we um we refer to her
as uh as big bird and i think that was
the first time we referred to her as a
bird and then i think this was the one
that set it off where it was like
calling her a bird became like a thing
but yeah i i agree meg i i think some of
that i don't think um
that stuff was really scripted i
remember on the day we when we were
shooting that
um
we just kept building and building and
building and just like at take after
take it was different every single time
and and
it's kind of amazing
how many people have i cut up
how many people have i murdered
how could be
yeah like but like i remember i
i remember
i mean it's it's it's pretty great
actually how it feels scripted in the
sense that it's so tight the back and
forth is so tight but
i'm i'm almost certain it was not it was
not scripted um and i love how caitlyn's
jumping in there it's so it's also so
funny to me that she is so
concerned with being
with fitting she's more con she would
rather fit the profile
um of a serial killer's victim
than uh you know not be considered a
young attractive blonde like she would
rather think of herself as someone who's
in danger of being murdered by serial
killer than to have us think that she's
not a young attractive blonde like that
is so that's so [ __ ] funny to me man
even just you in the bushes with a big
puffy coat is funny just the fact that
you had like
the puffiest coat we'd never see you
wear a coat like that before or after
but
you got it for that scene
which is great yeah it's great that was
a really funny back and forth with
pepper jack just how quickly
he asks her about who she's with and how
quickly he like assumes her so by the
time you get out of the bushes she's
already his best hoe and uh he's not
like it's just such a funny
fact he was great and and when we went
back to him this season to have him back
it must have
been so bizarre for him yeah no you're
right to to come in and do one scene as
a character on a show
and then 14 years later be called back
to play that same character i mean i
remember he was
he was so it was so great to see him
because he was so excited to come back
and he was
you know uh excited to step back into
those shoes and he i remember i asked
him i was like did you have to like
watch the episode like a few times to
remember the mannerisms and the
the way that he spoke and all that kind
of stuff and he he studied all that and
uh yeah it was a pleasure having him
back such a sweet dude do you guys
remember the origins of this episode did
it come out of like a law and order
thing like that you were
or don't remember but this is one of the
first episodes and we don't do too many
episodes like this but there's a certain
style of comedy right which is
mistaken information
where
one character thinks they're talking
about one thing the other character
thinks the character is talking about
something completely different
and the joke is basically coming from
that you know it's almost like a sort of
like a neil simon-esque
technique or whatever it feels
not dated but it feels like a more old
school in a way you know yeah it's it's
very it's very very typical of a of a
farce which you know we tend to be a
little bit more satirical and less
farcical but um
that's what it is yeah i i i think it's
great when we slip into that i i i think
it's um you know if if done well you
know it's like you you make a choice
like that you just kind of lean into it
and you don't question it too much and
you just kind of go with it um you know
characters talking at cross purposes one
person thinks that they're saying one
thing and the other person thinks
they're saying something totally
different and
uh i
you know i i kind of love that even
though and you know even though we've
talked about like how we don't
uh
well i guess rob's talked about how he
doesn't like it when we're spoofing um
things
um we do spoof to catch a predator which
is a ancient show um now
um but i just i love it i i think this
episode is very clever like uh we we met
we pack a lot of [ __ ] into this there's
a lot packed into this episode it's
pretty
it's pretty jam-packed with uh with good
stuff
i like how the scene is shot of you
chasing after mary elizabeth uh
with caitlyn
and if my memory serves me correctly
actually matt shackman shot that scene
it was i think it was jerry levine's
episode but i think because we were in
philly
and jerry couldn't come to philly matt
picked up that
i think you mentioned that yeah back on
the streets yeah i think you're right
yeah i think he shot the philly stuff
because we
uh jerry wasn't able to come to to
philly for some reason um and that's one
of the first times where we we have you
actually like considering possibly
killing someone that is so funny
and like i mean be like wait is this too
far for the character and
nothing would seem to be too far like
the further we could get we would just
chase down those roads for everybody
yeah that's what we were learning right
uh in this in this season as we were as
we've talked about many times in the
podcast like how we were pushing things
in this season to see how far we could
go um and
you know this was one of those things
where it was like well what if what if
he really does start fantasizing about
killing
this this this woman killing the
waitress
and uh
it's your disappointment when you have
to when you realize wait you're not
actually going to do that that's so
funny like oh yeah yeah forget
forgetting that we're not actually
killing her that we're just we're just
we're just going through all the steps
that lead up to the killing
and then be yeah and being and having to
switch gears
okay yes right
right okay yeah right we're not yeah no
of course back to the real world then
there's some disappointment in that
yeah and still not being able to totally
let it go being like you know just being
like
it'd be better if we could if i could
actually uh you know but yeah no you're
right
yeah the hands of going out to strangle
her
but no you're right you're right no
we're not gonna yeah uh
[Laughter]
um i also i love the twist i love i love
the uh i don't think you see the gary
thing coming at all i don't think you
see that coming at all it just comes off
like a
you know a schlub that uh that sweetie
is taking advantage of
and um
you know i i also love that we put the
question to him about the gardening
sheers of like do you do you think this
would cut through bone
and his answer the way he answers it the
way i think you interpret it as the
audience the first time you're seeing it
is is like uh i i guess like why would
someone ask me that right is the subtext
of that when really his subtext is like
oh i have to be careful how i answer
this because i know the answer to this
yeah yeah or like yeah do they know
something about me and how do they know
it
right yes yeah yeah yeah
but you're but by the way jumping
jumping to the end uh like your reaction
you know your your joy at having won the
case and then going to get a beer and
then i remember when we were shooting
that like
it was one of those things where like i
i don't know if we i don't maybe maybe
when we were because we always
you know when we do our three-man
rewrite of every episode we're always
acting this stuff out and
i do think that i do i
i think that i knew you were gonna do
something like that and getting to watch
you actually do it in the episode was
such a joy like that that the whole like
uh you know
their heads
it's it's a it's uh
yeah there might be a beer back there
but i'm not gonna go looking for it
yeah i think um i i think when we dr
i don't know if you remember this but
but uh when we got there on the day to
shoot that and they filled that fridge
with heads
it was all
it was all like
male heads there was like maybe one
woman and it was all dudes and i was
like there's something wrong where they
they looked terrible were they not
covered in frost we frosted them up
right so
uh i do i'm not sure about that um i do
remember however that that it was it
should have just been a a fridge full of
heads of young girls right because we
had established that it was young blonde
women yeah right but instead it was like
a it was a variety pack of of well those
are the ones that they found
right right you know yeah those are the
those are the ones that people were
concerned when they were missing
[Laughter]
he popped off a few sort of drifters as
well and
that's a good explanation
yeah i mean i do think that's actually
the case when when things like that
happen which is like you know i think
those people sort of test their skills
first on people that will
you know won't draw attention and then
why am i laughing
i don't know i don't want to know i've
always thought that the reason he was
killing blonde women was because he
couldn't have d and there was some
reason like because he clearly has
really infatuated with her did you guys
mean that that like he actually was
killing blonde women because he was
obsessed with her pictured anyone really
wanting to
that's sort of part of the lore of the
shows
it is really it is really it is very it
is very difficult
yes yeah it is very fun to like uh
oh oh
oh hey
hey man oh no way wow
i'm so sorry so much
thank you so much i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry how is she
jumping inside is it though
but seriously how itchy is it we've
already informed the audience that it
was you know it was worse
and the pinworms
and uh
i'm so sorry
this is terrible
all joking aside i'm so sorry your your
time is my time is not more valuable
than yours we agreed to this time
i [ __ ] it up
i'm late i did my best as you can see
i'm like
sweating um i'm schizing but i
i'm so sorry to you i'm so sorry to
megan i'm so sorry to the audience i
[ __ ] it up well also you're you're
mike is not
no it's not i literally just turned this
on and was like okay how quickly can i
get into this okay so we'll just scrap
that
for yeah don't let's not even bother
don't even bother to set it up we'll do
it yeah don't worry about it man just
leave it
it's not gonna work we'll do it later
nope your mic's off
i'm going to leave all this in the cut
it's just me apologizing for me [ __ ]
up
i'll just leave it it's fine we can hear
it yeah but it's not coming through that
mic so it's fine but just move it out of
the way and we'll just
we'll just take it through the audio
that next time baby you're gonna have
plenty of chances it's okay
hey okay
rob yes
yes calm down
calm down take a deep breath take a deep
breath take a deep breath grab a pee pee
grab a piece of ice or something rub it
all over your face and your body and
just
we'll get it there you go you get nice
right now look at my face look at my
nose is getting red again and i haven't
had any alcohol
so now i think we're realizing that when
i overheat
my nose just gets i don't know
either that or you're drinking now
during the day oh
what is that are you sure you're not
drinking
vodka
the bummer of it is is that well i feel
like we've been going over so many great
highlights of this episode did you get a
chance to watch it
i did and i loved it
i it's okay it's a good idea it's a good
it's really it's good right
what we haven't gotten into in this
episode is mac and and how good mac is
in this episode and you know you do a
gear in this episode that you do in max
banging dennis's mom where you have this
secret that you don't want anyone to
know and you you play it really funny
you have this thing where you like sort
of repeat people's sentences when they
speak to you
it's like you like they'll be like hey
mac how you doing you're like how you
doing like
some kind of thing that you do that's
really funny i don't know but i think
you do it in these two episodes and then
we never did it again but it's it's a
good way to go back to it
we should we should get you hiding
something
yeah it's also it's also funny like i
mean again you know we're always talking
about the characters just complete and
total obliviousness but one of my
favorite lines ever
of yours is in this episode when you're
talking to um
carmen and uh
you know she's saying
why i feel like you don't want to be
seen with me and you're like no i don't
mind being seen with you i just you know
uh whatever but like i but the line is
that that's the just one of my favorite
lines of yours ever is um
i'm not i'm not ashamed of you i'm
ashamed of myself
yes and that's supposed to be which i do
feel better
it's a good example right it's just a
great example of of saying something
that you think
is like you think you're saying some you
think you're saying like no you're
you're you're you're i'm not ashamed of
you yeah i'm ashamed of myself you're
great
you're great it's just that i'm ashamed
of being with you
yes yes
yeah which is just uh again that's us
was leaning all the way into it as far
as we could
yeah always making a joke about the
these pieces of [ __ ]
yeah yeah see i really like the moment
where you bring the wine coolers and
then she's like did you bring the
condoms and you're like not really into
the whole condom thing
not really into the whole condom thing
yeah
i there's so there's so many great
moments in this episode where characters
are are do we're doing the thing that we
do talk about where we're on the same
page overall but undercutting each other
along the way and disagreeing on the
details you know um you know just just
through the whole episode you know what
i mean just like um you know like
was this the first episode we see mac's
bedroom because of the the joke where
when frank walks in where he goes like
what's the what's the decor in here
what's the vibe in here what's he going
for that cell yeah
and and that that's actually um
you know the the more astute um creep
will pick up on the fact that um that
does not look like mac's bedroom because
it wasn't
it was actually dennis's bedroom that
was but we had that year for whatever
reason we didn't build your bedroom we
just thought like oh we'll just redress
dennis's bedroom and make it look like
mac's bedroom
so the orientation of that room where
the door doesn't make it where the bed
is
it doesn't track with with what we've
said your room looks like now um i don't
know why we didn't then build your room
to look like that that would have made
more sense
i think it was like a stage space thing
or whatever but uh yeah
yeah
it's always money it always comes down
to money we didn't have the money to do
it right
basically
it's both money and experience on our
part right to say like someone's cutting
corners on our behalf but like the three
of us didn't know to say hey let's not
cut that particular corner go ahead and
cut some other corner but that one
matters to us
you know yeah and that just comes with
experience
yeah
did you guys notice have you i don't
know if you talked about this already um
the that there's music there's ambient
music
that's playing in the background
of the scene in the in the hardware
store
that we're essentially saying is playing
in the background is actually playing in
the store that would be source
and it is now score that we use
as transitional music and actually we
use it quite often
yeah that was the first that was the
first time we'd ever used that song
was it was as source music um for the
listener or creep out there who doesn't
know that i think you'd explained it but
yeah source when you put source music in
that means you're putting music in
that's actually playing that's actually
supposed to be in the in in the scene
with the characters coming from a car
radio a
speaker at a restaurant
as opposed to scoring iphone which as
opposed to score which the characters
don't hear because that's yeah score but
um
i didn't no i didn't i didn't notice
that i don't even know what is it
no it's faster paced in fact we should
probably play that clip right now
[Music]
[Applause]
uh gang we want you to know that this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
if you're not familiar with betterhelp
it's an online therapy service that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with licensed therapists all
around the world
how it works is you answer questions and
better help assesses your needs and
matches you with the right person to
talk to in less than two days it's not
just about who's around you or who's
available it's about who's best for you
yeah i've actually used better help
before because i had a sort of temporary
problem that i wanted to see a therapist
quickly about and it was really really
easy to use i signed up and they matched
me with someone really quickly well
that's about yeah i mean that's the best
part of it right you get matched to the
the person that's the most right for you
you're not like
tethered to you know whoever's in your
area whoever's available whoever you can
get an appointment with you can get uh
matched with the right person from all
over the world and you don't have to
sit in traffic and go to the person's
office you get to just do it right from
your laptop computer that's right always
sunny podcast listeners get 10 off their
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
sunny
creeps you are already reading this with
your eyeballs but listeners that's
h-e-l-p
not better health go to better help
betterhelp.com
sunny for 10 off your first month of
therapy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that
okay so so we had never used that as
score before uh we found it used it as
source and then we were like oh that's
that's good let's uh let's start using
it as score
or maybe we had and we just didn't care
i don't know we were like oh maybe it
can be both
oh i wouldn't put it past us to have
used at a score and then just used it as
source because it was the only thing
that fit that we liked and we didn't
want to spend a bunch of time
um yeah more money
what about pepper jack
we talked about he didn't make it but we
haven't gone into in-depth into it
yeah he's amazing
this is the first this is the first
mention of larry bird you've already
talked about that
we have yes is the first met yeah the
second mention though of of dee being a
bird first being uh called a big bird in
the basketball episode but then this one
first time we called her larry bird
and then and then i think it that's
where it took right then then she became
then we just started calling her bird
after that right
yeah
i don't remember
such a weird delay there's a weird delay
in and i don't know if it's if it's
because we're waiting for each other to
speak or if there's actually just a
delay
but i i'm like there's like a full
second after somebody speaks to where
somebody else speaks and it's really
[ __ ] up the rhythm is anybody else
feeling that or am i just coming in and
[ __ ] up a rhythm that you guys
created and it was working
i know i won't say we were like
on fire that we had to think about it
though that was just okay okay okay i
was thinking uh uh i was gonna i was
gonna pause for a full three seconds and
i was really hoping that you would do
the same thing just like fake freezing
well there was like an 18 minute delay
in you showing up rob yeah i don't know
it was a 18 minute drink i felt that
yeah um we sure felt that
and then we've repeated some things here
so that's part of it like an echo i'm
sorry i don't know
megan didn't you have some didn't you
have some questions for us did you want
to prompt us on anything or did have
some questions for you one is um have
you ever dated anyone that you kept from
your like friends and family like didn't
want anyone to know about
yeah
you have
you have
well i mean not since i've been married
she said like it's the most lascivious
thing ever
um but what was this were you hiding the
details what were you ashamed of i was
thinking it was a shame well i it was it
was weird to me you know this was
something that came i think a little bit
later in my dating
life uh where
if i was dating somebody but it wasn't
like my girlfriend and it was like
serious
i kept i kind of kept it separate from
the rest of my life because it felt
weird you're like
you guys always had those friends right
who who were just you were just like
every single time you hung out with them
they were like dating a new person and
you're like oh look okay and they're
like yeah this is uh so-and-so and
you're like oh like okay you're i
thought what happened to what happened
you know
i'm dating this person now
you know and you're just like
okay do you have to introduce me to
every [ __ ] that you date like
really seriously you're gonna [ __ ]
bring like always bringing like like it
brings an energy to like a get-together
or a party
that like kind of can throw [ __ ] off if
it's like
if you don't know for sure that that
person's gonna click with your group of
friends or whatever but like you know i
don't know so i i kept it separate
actually
sadly keep it separated manny got us
well i i i kept the fact that i was
dating my spouse um she was not my
spouse at the time but i was dating my
co-star from you guys so maybe that
would count
yeah that counts sure that's a big yeah
it's idiotic yeah that's great
it's crazy that i didn't see it it's
[ __ ] crazy because she used to she
would she would she would we'd be in our
apartment and she would be like i'm just
going to go to sleep on the you know we
had we built that big like
that big mattress platform thing that we
could watch movies on and [ __ ] she'd
just like pass out on that and then
i'd wake up the next morning and uh you
know she was there and i was just like
yeah we were counting on the fact that
you're always just doing your own thing
yeah
you were just focused on what you were
doing and we were like glenn's not going
to notice [ __ ]
trust me and you're all good you were
totally right i i did not go to school
right
yeah
uh that's one yeah i don't feel like you
needed to keep secret
but no i i understand
but actually for the same reason that
glenn but that glenn brought up which is
that
if it didn't work out and that i think
we were even mature enough at the time
to recognize like look if this doesn't
work out we don't want it to ruin the
dynamic of the tv show because the tv
show's working and we can keep it
professional and personal sort of
separate so if we brought you into it
and it and then it kind of fell apart it
would might just be weird and i think
that was a huge part of it too
yeah totally
uh i don't think i ever kept a
relationship secret they were hard to
get um so if i got one you know
everybody knew
and then i've been in one for
i don't know
55 60 years now good long stretch so
does anybody keep anything to themselves
anymore because it feels as though no i
don't want to be the old man uh out here
in the podcast space bitching about the
the next generation because it's not the
next generation it's everybody it's
everybody of our generation it's every
our parents generation below everybody
is just
they're not holding anything back at any
point everybody needs to be expressing
themselves at all times and they need to
feel heard at all times and it doesn't
matter
if if maybe it's something so private
that you could just maybe navigate that
yourself you don't need to bring that
out into the world uh and be heard at
all times i know that oftentimes i'm a a
real piece of [ __ ] and if i express
myself and i'm in those moods i it's
publicly i immediately maybe the four or
five times i've done it i'm like oh that
was so stupid that's not me that's not
representative of who i am
do you feel that way doesn't represent
me
um
but because i felt the need to tell
everybody everything in this exact
moment and i have access to everybody at
every moment
i [ __ ] it up
i definitely don't uh tend to over share
in that way uh probably for the same
reasons that you're you know you don't
it's that it seems weird to me i mean
and it's not you know i have no problem
sharing things and being very authentic
and honest about what's going on i mean
i think we've we've hit moments like
that often on this podcast where you
know we get very we stop down and we get
very real and we're not making jokes and
[ __ ] and we're just you know talking
about real stuff but um but yeah i don't
feel the need to share every aspect of
my life with uh with everyone and and
you know to be clear
it wasn't that i ever kept a
relationship a secret i never i never
like purposely was like ooh i can't let
anyone know it was just i kept them sep
it was more like i kept them separate i
kept those things separate it was like i
had my group of friends and then i had
someone that i was dating and you know
and i think that's totally fair to be
like i don't know about this person yet
and i'm sure i want to like cross that
bridge of bringing them into my
friends which you probably prioritized
at that time in your life and it's you
know look i'm deeply uncomfortable
sharing stuff i rarely like post
anything on the internet i'm not on
twitter
uh i don't know why i guess i could kind
of do some work on that but
uh but i don't think i i know why it's
because you're you're you're a private
person and i think that's very normal to
be a private person and and and also
like it does color
you know if too much of your life is out
there uh for everyone to know about and
see you know it colors their perception
of you every time you play a character
i mean i know for me i agree with that
look i think also glenn you and i
i know specifically got into this
because we had a love for acting and we
had a love for a very certain style of
acting which i don't know if it exists
anymore but like you know we were
idolizing those sort of 70s
you know iconic actors that
some are methods some weren't method but
that the acting was the most paramount
thing in their life and you didn't know
much about them personally so that every
time they appeared on screen you were
like oh man i'm going to get to see
fill in the blank what daniel day lewis
you know which you know kind of nothing
about but you want to go see him in the
theater or joaquin phoenix or somebody
um
i don't like this that line has blurred
so much you know between
uh
being a celebrity and being a uh like a
personality you know like
we kind of we we touched on this a
little bit last time we were talking
about the whole like paris hilton thing
and i was you know jokingly
half jokingly saying that i find that
whole thing disgusting but uh but like i
i just have i've always been very
uncomfortable with the idea of being
famous now
i would like to draw a distinction
between
you know just being sort of a celebrity
in general and
being someone for whom your work means
something to them right so
like i i i absolutely love it when
somebody who's a big fan of sunny or
anything that i've done comes up and
it's like hey man i really like your
work that feels good to me i'm like this
person enjoyed my work that's what i
wanted to that's what i always wanted to
put out into the world i never wanted to
be a personality i never wanted to be
like a
celebrity or whatever i just i just you
know wanted to do good work and you know
i when that's appreciated it's great but
like
you know to be famous for
i don't know like
whatever people get famous for these
days that that's not well there is the
other
point with fame where it it really can
become like um
you know you look at like pete davidson
who i like so much i've i've worked with
him and and that's great man he's funny
he's a great great guy and i think he's
super funny and talented you start
dating kim kardashian and all the eyes
of the world are on you and you're in a
different level of fame and
how does that affect people when you
show up in a movie
hard to say you know but in terms of
like in terms of like sunny fans coming
up to us it's great like
i love people knowing the show and i
like when people come up to me and say
that they like the show and i kind of
want to go back to something i said two
episodes ago where megan you were asking
about us about memes and i made a joke
that it was meaningless to me or
whatever
the truth is i love it like when i read
memes i [ __ ] laugh my ass off because
they're all hilarious i love that
anytime someone wants to refer to
someone is insane they put up a picture
of me in front of their corkboard like
that's like one of the best things
that's ever happened to me in my life
yeah
any conspiracy theory is is like is
often the meme is often you from that
episode yeah yeah but i also don't want
to just constantly be on the internet
telling people what i'm eating for
breakfast and uh and i and i'm really
grateful that we don't get like chased
around by paparazzi which you know we
all know people who are like that and
it's
it's tough on their on them you know
that's a crazy life i would
really struggle with that i can tell you
that right now it it it's it's
terrifying to me it's this weird thing
where like
but you also recognize that celebrity
has it has value in helping you to get
the kind of gigs that you want as an
actor right so if you mean something to
people if you are a celebrity if you're
big enough celebrity and you have a big
enough following or like fan base or
whatever
uh you're more likely to get those big
roles that you want
the moment in time that you're
you're referring to charlie which was
yes the 70s and 80s but it was really
like a hundred years of popular culture
um that we were at the tail end of where
you were making connections with
characters in movies and or television
shows
and you were identifying with them and
you were making those connections and
they were bringing you
a different perspective of life they
were bringing you joy they were bringing
you sadness they were bringing you of
the full range of human experience and
you had a connection to those characters
and i think what's happening now
or has been happening for the last 15 20
years and very acutely now is that
i think people's connections to
characters has changed in so far as we
we are now for example giving access to
people in a way that that we hadn't in
the past we've only done it through the
work but this would be an example
of the podcast itself where we're giving
access to people
in a way that we haven't done before
it's actually us and you i think that's
this huge part of why social media is
such a huge
uh such a huge part of our culture now
is because
people are getting past that artifice
and they're having now a connection with
you as you are
now whether or not we're willing to give
that to them is the that's the scary
line right but but i think it's still
the same in so far as it's people
seeking to identify with another human
being a character or a real person but
someone who brings a little bit more
light to their life
yeah i think then it boils down to like
what
what do you want personally in terms of
like what do you want to give not like
what are you capable of giving but like
what
what do you want to give like
um i'm finding
this to be a good experience just
because of connecting with you guys and
i'm glad that it's reaching an audience
and connecting them too um
the thing that turns me on the most just
as a person is making
so let me use a hoity-toity word but
making a piece of art right like uh
making an episode of the show making a
movie like really
kind of creating and making a thing
which is not me in my life but that's
pretty much all i care about like that's
just my passion in life that's what
that's what excites me that's what i
feel like gives me meaning and purpose
uh so it's interesting trying to but
it's a balance right because i also know
okay if i go do that if i go do whatever
horrible bosses or i want you back
there's an expectation from the studio
that i also
sell the movie by selling myself right
so like go on a talk show go be you you
know like
go on a show where you eat increasingly
hot hot sauce which i think when i went
on i remember being kind of in a grumpy
mood being like wait where am i what am
i doing and then of course i'm doing
what the [ __ ] happened i know and now
it's like one of my favorite things
pacino never did a hot sauce show
but kind of yeah kind of
yeah it's just whatever your art
whatever your artistic line is right i
mean like the line okay so
as a fan of glenn
as a fan of glenn i recognize i can see
in his camera that he's staying in a
hotel room there's a part of me that
wants to know how many times today or
since you got to the hotel room have you
masturbated i want to know now i want to
know that as your friend i want to know
that as a fan of yours because i find it
fun i'm picturing you
landing and being like i haven't been
away from my family in like a year and a
half i'm going to lock this door and i'm
going to beat my dick like it owes me
money and i'm going to do it for like a
like a solid three hours yeah i like to
drink a couple i'm going to strip at
least three or four layers of skin off
this thing
yeah you know what i mean like there's
gonna be people banging on his hotel
wall being like are you okay in there
is everything okay
i hear a lot of screaming
are you okay
there's so much screaming
voices is it how many people are in
there it's just one yeah it's just one
i'm an actor don't worry about it it's
fine i i play all the characters i'm
getting into character
it's like an eddie murphy thing every
time i masturbate all right just
just getting my character leave me alone
don't talk right now not now don't talk
to me now
um so i i can understand the the desire
from
a person out there in the world like i
wouldn't i think that would be amazing
if i'm listening to
uh smartlist and i and and and jason
were to go check himself into a hotel
room and he started would start talking
about that i would find it absolutely
fascinating and probably hilarious but
there's also a weird connection because
anybody that's alone or have been alone
or away from people for the first time
in a long time knows exactly what that
feeling is like but we don't talk about
it a lot in public because it's either
base or private or whatever i get that
too and i also understand why you
wouldn't want to tweet that out to the
world
but yet i still want to be out here
yeah sure i mean that's why you built a
whole separate little house for yourself
right so that you could just have it
right that's yeah you're calling me why
you were so sweaty and 18 minutes late
it's right yes
look this was not for sweat oh no
oh
but the listener at home is holding up a
darkness
oh i thought it was a raccoon
all right
i think megan almost threw up
yeah there's been look
look i spend a lot of time down here
i'm a human being
yeah of course from time to time i find
the time for myself
you have needs and a high speed internet
connection and
that leads to another and
[Laughter]
somebody brought to my attention and i
don't want to uh
i don't want to kick horses while
they're down but the johnny depp and
amber heard thing like apparently in
their trial somebody had pooped in the
bed and the and they were talking about
like who pooped to bed and sonny fans
were delighted by this fact yeah of
course like it is a strange it is a
strange reaction to something to be like
i'm gonna [ __ ] in bed
oh [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] bed i'm going to [ __ ] the
bed
how do you like me now i [ __ ] the best
oh wait wait was it done on purpose
oh i have not been reading i've not been
reading someone just told me about this
and i'm like yeah oh i think it was
eventually
yeah if it's a high stress uh
ex excretion um then
it's going to come out in a blast it's
going to come out wet and it's going to
come out fast yeah poop with the tea
again i feel like i'm boring i'm not
only boring sexually i'm boring with
like my revenge schemes that would never
occur to me what
i'm going to go i'm going to have you
been doing a lot of revenge
i mean i dabble in it i dabble in it but
not to the not to that extent
yeah
yeah i i i
you know with the ola and i an eye for
an eye you know makes the whole world
blind thing you know what i mean
very sweetly and casually saying charlie
he very earnestly i'm not big on revenge
which is very smash yeah just kind of
believe that
i don't dabble in revenge i was just
making a crack i i'm trying to think if
if i
i think there are consequences
meaning like there i think there are
natural consequences to treating me a
certain way but i wouldn't call that
that's not revenge
but here's what here's what freaks me
out about revenge i'm too scared that
the person will then take it another
step even further exactly you know what
i mean that it's like oh someone did
something to you and then you're like
okay great i'm gonna poop in a box and
mail to them and then they're like gonna
poop in a box for the rest of my life
mailed to me i'm like no way i don't
know you get into that with the wrong
person and boy yeah
some people are better at revenge than
others for sure yeah and they'll they'll
just keep going yeah
yeah i think my issue with revenge is
that i once i can get zero to a ten very
quickly as we all can to a certain
extent but i then i'm in the moment i
can see me doing something irrational
but
but 15 minutes later 20 minutes later i
feel like i can come calm down and then
the idea of some level of retribution
for whatever happened
would not occur to me
i don't think meg you spent a lot of
time with me have you noticed that my
um that you've been revengeful no you're
so like good at confrontation in the
moment that i don't ever see you like
waiting
for later to like like you would just
say it you know outright like i always
say that my favorite part about working
well with any of you guys in the in the
writer's room is that i've worked for
some showrunners that i can tell like i
pitched something that they don't like
and they do this like whole song and
dance of like letting me down gently by
like oh yeah that's interesting let's
consider that idea but you guys are
great because you'll just be like nah
that's not it and then
just move on and i kind of appreciate
that because like the the there's
something patronizing about like needing
to let me down gently as opposed to just
like being confrontational be like no
that's not it because there's an
assumption there that i'll come up with
a better idea if you just tell me you
don't like that one so i i prefer that
which is like just throw out the parts
like i remember pitching um the gang
replaces d with a monkey to you guys and
like the first time that i was pitching
it like i think there was a whole
different story and then the monkey was
just like a very small part of it you
guys were like well we like the monkey
but like basically get rid of the rest
of it yeah and then i was like
and that was and as i recall that was
coming on the heels of of another
conversation about something else where
we were talking about something being
too broad yeah and we were like we don't
want to tip into too broad and then we
left to go do something else we came
back you pitched us to sorry and you
very reticently were like okay and
there's a a point at which we possibly
replaced d with a monkey
and and you were like like just waiting
for the like that's [ __ ] crazy but
instead we were like well now hang on a
second what if the whole thing was the
monkey you know i mean just like yeah
in this season there is sort of a joyful
like silliness to some of the stuff that
we
might not approach anymore which season
three
yeah which i'm finding works better than
i thought where i'm like oh this is
whatever we're just we're interrogating
mac's mom and with the headphones and
the mic chainsaw thing that you want
frank to take your picture with the
chainsaw and yeah
like tongue things yeah yeah the
the little bow you put on your mom's
head or whatever we'd probably still do
that but that's just so [ __ ] fun but
that's that's
communication
we've we've had that form of
communication since the beginning and i
think that that that really is born out
of respect you're creating a room full
of people and everybody the assumption
is everybody deserves to be there
because they've earned earned it and now
if there's an idea that comes up that
that that isn't good enough it's not
like you're taking someone's whole self
of self-worth and saying no you're
you're not only are you wrong but you're
incapable it's more just like no the
idea didn't work but you're not
identifying the idea with your ego
you're just saying no great that didn't
work move on um so yeah it's like born
out of respect and i think that was
something we've always done isn't it
like i would never in the beginning we
would never like have someone pitch us
something like that's so stupid you
idiot you know like that's no but we
also like we wouldn't like put on kid
gloves and be like that's a really good
idea let's think about we'd be like nah
that doesn't that doesn't feel right
what else
and then just keep going yeah yeah yeah
keep going and we do that to each other
constantly
yeah
let's say danny line
yeah something like that but not that
[Music]
were you guys into true crime stuff at
all like did you do you ever cause this
episode's all about like kind of
like true crime type serial killer stuff
do you guys ever get into that
i'm into that to a certain extent but
but i definitely know that's more of a
female thing like i all the women in my
life are super into that like 20 20 and
dateline and stories of women being
dismembered and
murdered for some reason appeal to i
don't know is that you think you're
getting tricks as to how you're going to
evade the killer but i also noticed that
caitlyn even the ones where it's like
killer women i'm like oh i get this i
understand chick she was physically or
emotionally abused and she took she took
revenge and poisoned her husband and
killed him and caitlyn's like nah i
don't care for that
which ones are the ones you want to
watch and she's like i don't know like
like the woman's been gone for 20 years
and what happened to her we don't know
that's so [ __ ] up what is that right
i think
i think it's because like at least i
watched them and it's like it's both yes
like you pick up it's like things you're
afraid of so then you watch it and
you're like okay well
like note never do this thing but also i
like feeling superior to the victims
because there's always a moment where
i'm like well i wouldn't have done that
and therefore i wouldn't have died that
way so i i have like a [ __ ] cut that
cut that cut that
wait a second don't cut that don't cut
that
megan gan
blame superior to victims she's she's
learning she's learning
well you're learning you're learning
you're like oh yeah yeah yeah i wonder
no i get that from a primal like i get
that primally which is like it's all
survival of the fittest and you're
saying oh i don't want to be murdered i
would never have made that mistake
therefore i'm safe i wouldn't be
murdered yes yeah that's right i get
that i like the detective aspect of it
like like like if you listen to serial
you've got to kind of play detective
right you get you started to like get
all the suspect but then i always hit a
moment where i'm like oh man this is
somebody's real life like somebody's
somebody's dead and somebody's like kid
is dead like what the [ __ ] you know like
this is not my
we we made a joke about this later in
the season where we said like murder is
the new like like chips right this is
not just chips for me to snack on this
is like somebody's [ __ ] life it's
awful but also also but it's compelling
right because we're terrible well tell
your story faster tell it faster
[Laughter]
you shouldn't you know what i mean like
cereal was one of those things where i
was like oh my god this is like
absolutely fascinating fascinating
for about three episodes and then i'm
like all right get to it [ __ ] wrap
this [ __ ] up you [ __ ] jerks
it was the same way with uh
uh you know uh making a murderer or
whatever it was like
you know they stretched out i just have
[ __ ] i can't stand it when people tell
me a a [ __ ] two-hour long story in 10
hours i'm like just god
[ __ ] drives me crazy man so now if i
see like a true crime series or whatever
like a thing that's like oh it's gonna
the story's gonna unfold over uh uh even
four episodes
if it takes you four episodes even
that's too much for me i'm like i'll do
two i'll do two
two one hour episodes that that's how
much [ __ ] time you've got to tell me
this story otherwise i'm out i'm out
because because unlike the victim you
have a life to live you know you've got
stuff oh my god
damn maggot
jesus christ um i uh
why are you talking about masturbating
for like so long but i whatever yeah no
it doesn't there's that
usually in the patriarchy in the
patriarchy we talk about masturbation in
the matriarchy you guys are conceiving
very
rich webs of revenge and i i this is
terrifying
i mean listeners creeps and listeners be
afraid of the matriarchy because
like all we want to do is just like talk
about like our dicks and masturbation
like women are out there i wonder what
percentage of our audience just
masturbates to the podcast
you know there's probably like like one
one person right at least should we give
somebody should we give them something
should we should we take our shirts off
no like yeah like no it's like you know
every time you say like the letter s or
p or like you you're you know
that kind of weird [ __ ]
what maybe yeah i don't know it's okay
there's got to be one one person out
there right with with a kink
in the background
david hornsby once shared a video that
somebody sent to him of i think two guys
having sex and in the background was a
good girls episode that he was in um
just like
wait a second wait a second wait a
second
how did he get this video i don't know
but he sent it to me like a while ago it
was so funny because like the guys were
like really going at it you didn't ask
him how he got how he found this video
like it was like homemade porn that
someone put on the internet and he was
in the back
yeah yeah it was great i don't know how
he yeah i should ask him how he got it
um we've discussed my erotic tales for
on this podcast before right we did
right we covered that not on the podcast
no
you guys know that you know this story
right
yeah well yeah i mean it's been a very
long time since since we've talked about
it
i was one of my first uh so i i had an
agent like a real agent and they were
sending me on things i remember i
auditioned for like wet hot american
summer and like got a couple callbacks
and and i think i was in the same
casting office and they had an another
audition it was a short film short movie
it was called angela
and it was starring victor argo or
whatever
um
and basically
my role was just there were two guys
sitting in a bar having a conversation
about sex like they had hooked up with
some girl and victor argo's overhearing
their conversation and he's sort of
depressed about
being past his sexual prime
and by the way i don't even have the
bulk of the dialogue i think i'm just
the guy be like uh-huh oh wow man like
that's like my part
and i remember and the director's name
was like amos colic or something like
that uh israeli director i think and um
i get the part and i go down the set
we're filming it shot on film
and uh
boy this guy is up my ass like tons of
notes like he's just hating my
performance i'm like man i'm just
sitting here going uh-huh yeah i can't
make this guy happy
uh but it's whatever i shoot the couple
hours they let me go
never hear about it movie kind of
disappears
and then like
a year or two or maybe even longer it
might be like five years later it shows
up on my imdb as erotic tales force
summer of my deflowering
and and so i guess it was like kind of
like
soft coreish porn like
not porn but like like uh cinemax you
didn't get the whole script
they didn't give you an answer no i just
got the scene but it's no longer on
there apparently i was cut out of the
movie i think
some some
uh super fan had found the dvd and
looked it up and uh
and
my scene would no longer exist
i would like to see that which i have
mixed feelings about on the one hand i'm
relieved and on the other hand i also
would like to see the scene
yeah right right of course
glenn how many times have you
masturbated
i i i'm not i'm not going to uh know how
many times he's not going to dignify
that question
i'm not going to dignify
i got in last night
oh so it's it's between one and three
relax
relax
um guys i gotta pee uh can we end this
[ __ ] thing jesus christ you guys have
done it
we have to have done it we did it uh
well rob thanks for joining us